isn't it great oh happy hump day america
summer is just around the corner i can
smell the lotion
and the fear
so at twitter headquarters casualties
are mounting there's crying sobbing
there's fainting and that was just a
janitor unclogging a men's room toilet
yesterday elon musk called out twitter's
censer for suppressing the new york post
bombshell article about hunter biden it
was a deserved jab directed at twitter's
legal chief vijaya gotti hope i got that
right
[Laughter]
it is fun to say though
now right after musk bought the company
gotti got called a virtual meeting which
is just like a normal meeting except
there's vodka in your world's best mom
coffee mug or if you're jeffrey tubin
heavy cream hey
boom i swear i wouldn't do more of those
jokes but i lied now to some she's seen
at the comp as the company's moral
authority you know like i am here at fox
now gotti is scared because musk has
called for twitter to embrace free
speech advocating open source twitter's
algorithm while suggesting it should
only remove content if it's required by
law
that upsets gotti who only wants certain
voices to be heard and labels others as
either hate speech or disinformation
she's the sensor and one with her thumb
on the scale or in twitter's case her
two left feet
and according to politico in that
virtual meeting she cried over the
uncertainties to come but is that really
why she cried i'm not so sure and i'm an
expert on making women cry
it's just a reaction they have when they
see me in person the new king of late
night greg godfather
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah they'll never have me
now gotti's made over 17 million bucks
as the censor including 7 million in
2020. that's more than i made last year
working here and moonlighting as a
runway model for wilhemina
and like my appetite for fermented horse
milk her salary doubled in 2021. yet the
media acts like she's a vulnerable
underling bullied by an egomaniacal
tyrant sorry she's crying because she
knows her loss of power means her loss
of future millions meanwhile the media
continues to go bonkers cue the freaks
what the right has already seized is
this ground that they're on the side of
free speech they're really not they're
for the political version of yelling
fire in a movie theater elon musk i
guess he you know he misses the old
south africa in the 80s he wants he
wants that back yeah there it is when
you got no argument call people racist
and if anyone tries to defend the charge
you're considered even more racist it's
the old have you stopped beating your
wife ploy no matter how you respond you
sound guilty it explains msnbc's refusal
to can this nut bag the grift works they
can't fire her she'll sue them for
racism but with her ratings that suit
should get thrown out like it was worn
by jimmy failure
but as musk is showing this smears
crumbling under its own hysteria now
when i was growing up all i heard about
was mccarthyism joe mccarthy was the
evil senator who launched the witch hunt
for undercover communists who had
infiltrated the government universities
film industry this was in the 1950s when
it actually might not have been true
ultimately the smear tactics led to his
downfall he also harmed the
anti-communism movement turning many
people into anti-anti-communists
bernie sanders for short
now whenever the hollywood or the media
tries to play hero or victim they play
the mccarthyism card how brave they were
to stand up to this fear-mongering but
today it's all different who are the new
mccarthyites well musk has exposed them
the actual repression today is almost
entirely done by left-wingers using a
campaign that spreads fear of alleged
racist or homophobic influence on
american institutions they use emotion
and feelings to manipulate you but
they're misery merchants making money
off demonization it's again part of the
big flip the free speeches are no longer
on the left but on the right the
pro-women's movement is no longer on the
left but on the right these days the
only people who want to save women's
sports are lesbian feminists and people
who watch tucker carlson
talk about strange bedfellows picture
pat boone spooning billie jean king
i am
the big flip is also happening in
entertainment back in the 80s it was the
right who said rock music turns kids
into satanists or worse democrats now
it's the right fighting for comedians to
say what they want and it's the left
acting as censor claiming that words are
weapons pretty soon the tsa will let you
board without the right pronouns the
left has turned into everything they
claimed to hate and then some they're
jesse helms they're phyllis schaffly
they're john lithgow and footloose
and yes they're joe mccarthy it's like
they had a three-way and produced keith
olbermann
and the other side well elon musk is now
our thomas jefferson the father of free
speech
the babylon b is our new york time it's
our new new york times joe rogan's our
cnn and tyrus he's our walter cronkite
with more tattoos than an ms-13 gang
member damn right yes and what am i you
could say i'm your merry prankster
sharing the fun and the risk with you
but whatever i am you could be sure i'm
probably going to be called a racist
transphobic sexist for it which thanks
to the left doesn't mean
let's welcome tonight's guest
she's handled more scoops than an
octopus at baskin-robbins new york post
business reporter lydia moynihan
his stylist has a seeing-eye dog
box across america host jimmy bailar
her pediatrician once said she was full
of life before he whipped out the lice
comb
fox news contributor cad tip
and the last doctor who checked his
reflexes got punted 50 yards my massive
sidekick in the nwa world television
champion tyrus
boom
still still number one
still number one uh and there's a lot of
a lot of uh maserati talk when i said
maserati you didn't hear me say that's
code for snow cone and you guys were
talking over that so everybody gets a
snow cone that was in the room you
specifically said in the room correct
yes yes okay yes i stake my life on it
tyrus all right
can't wait for snow cone day oh yeah
snow cone is yeah and you know what cat
you know what snow cone is code for
what i can't tell you but i can't wait
for snow cone day either
lydia welcome to the show
i'm so glad to be here oh that makes one
of us
that was such an adolescent phrase
you delivered it very well thank you
well you are like a bit you you may get
a lot of business scoops tell us
something that we might not know about
what's going on behind the scenes like
all these all of these people trashing
elon musk on their uh on their internal
emails what's it called slash or
something
slack shows how much i know anyway i
think i think that's going to be coming
out in the coming days but i just want
to say this whole overreaction to elon
musk buying twitter i mean you would
think the way people are talking that
twitter was this like shangri-la where
there was elevated discussion about
human flourishing and the meaning of
life yeah the reality is like twitter is
a hellhole
toxic cesspool where people dm you and
tell you that you look like your face
got hit by a shovel and they hope you
die so i was kidding
and i didn't say shovel oh god were you
were you the one who asked us to snort
cocaine off me too yes oh my god it all
makes sense now
any compliment yes especially
i don't snort coke off just anything
drag humble brag uh no but look i don't
think it can get worse than it already
is right and i mean the idea that you
would put the algorithm online so
there's transparency so people can see
it like i personally would love to know
why donald trump is not allowed on
twitter but the ayatollah khomeini of
iran is
and president vladimir putin also has an
account i think i think i don't know it
can't get worse than it is elon musk has
a lot of ideas he's a visionary i'm i'm
here for it all right boom well jimmy
why are they so scared why are they so
scared of the first amendment they think
it's like your jacket
to the core
stinking of dead hobo
i thought you would like my shoes
they're a tribute to the yellow brick
road you told dorothy to follow in the
wizard of oz
nicely done this was a shout out to you
king of late night thank you my favorite
thing in the world is like for a bunch
of people who swore that twitter didn't
favor them they seem really concerned
with the change of management it's great
point and to lydia's brilliant point
about like oh this site's going to
change what do you mean like twitter is
a fight club for people who don't want
to get hit you go on there's always a
confrontation waiting for you and for
that reason if you're going to own
twitter he's not going to censor
anything for the most part because it
would defeat the whole point of twitter
which is conflict it's incentivized
conflict yeah but everybody who's
yelling and screaming like joy reid
about oh elon musk and he's encouraging
the worst kinds of free speech let's not
forget her twitter account tweeted the
most homophobic things we've ever heard
and we were told the fbi is looking into
it because she was hacked this is a
really long investigation that was 2015.
yeah and back and nicole willis doing
the same thing with the right is seizing
is free speech yo he's not saying
no one can do what they want on the left
it's no different than the mask argument
mass mandates ending doesn't mean you
can't wear a mask it means anybody
they want i'm sorry i'm passionate about
this but the truth is this is why
they're over protesting as they lost
that key causal of censorship it always
went their way and they're sad to see it
leave in town and it's no i don't know
if there's any worse disinformation than
weapons of mass destruction yeah wasn't
that nicole wallace's wife biggest ever
biggest ever yeah let's go to war and
kill tens of thousands of people and
spend billions of dollars because we
know they have weapons of mass
destruction they didn't have yeah thank
you yeah very good very good
tyrus um i feel like we got like a fun
like i said this on the five a fun free
election
like we we won something
we won something this week and it's kind
of fun to watch the people who dislike
us so much
break down in public yeah it's it's kind
of like uh the guy who was
assistant to the assistant
gm and he's reminded that that position
does not exist
so we've got
basically dwight schrute throwing a
temper tantrum over at twitter and we're
all jim so that's for the office
reference i've even seen it
what's that show
the office but yeah thank you i never
see it on tv yeah okay it's never on no
one uh
the the more
the more
elon says less
because he hasn't said anything yeah
he's not he hasn't come out on a pulpit
in a speech and started saying the
following people are banned from twitter
and welcome back and then he's having an
evil award banquet dinner with
president trump and and anyone who's
ever been
you know like welcome back and we're
having all kinds of big reveals on on
twitter of all these evil geniuses that
are back and that's a great idea yeah
you know and the twitter bird has been
chained and changed to a confederate
flag like all of a sudden like it's like
it's coming out now you know it's the
it's the whole thing
it brings out the absolute worst in in
people joey her comment about apartheid
he was 17 years old when he left south
africa i don't know how big of a
political mover and shaker he was at 17.
yeah i mean i get he's an overachiever
but i don't think he he was doing a lot
and he left yes which is a good sign
when you leave a country that you're not
really feeling what's going on so yeah
that's probably one of the worst things
i've ever heard and if that was reversed
in any way if you would have said that
about anybody else i would not be here
anymore and not just here anywhere yeah
and god knows i've tried to say things
and if there was ever a reason to cancel
somebody is to say
that type of statement apartheid was a
horrible horrible moment in history in
the world and you're accusing somebody
of that because you're mad because he
bought something exactly makes no sense
at all cat no sense at all
what is in your brain right now that you
would like to express publicly in front
of millions
i always forget about the second part
talk who's having a convo
um i don't i think it's great because
i've gotten so many more new followers
yes they're all boss they're all but do
you think that
do you think that like fake things
making me look better is something below
me no like look at me
my process of getting ready for work is
like identical to that of a drag queen
yes
it is i mean i said yes fake hair fake
lashes i'm sure we wear the exact same
kind of bras
so as long as i'm looking good that's
all you know i'm gonna say it's a win
that's interesting so you look at bots
almost as like it's cosmetics it is
cosmetic that's exactly what it is
that's when you gain followers too yes i
gained thousands thousands i couldn't
keep track but they're all real and
they're young and they're beautiful it's
weird i just
i didn't see them and they're sliding
into your dms
what does that mean oh
all right we got to move on dennis
ministry yes
up next should student loan debt be
forgiven willy nilly or is that idea
just plain silly hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else